HERE TONIGHT, THERE'S A FEW   H
GAME.
>> JODY: 2,000 PENALTY MINUTES
IN THE OES TO THE
OF THE CROWD.AVRIKOV,
>> JODY: LOT OF GOOD THI THE
POINT.
THAT WASPALMIERI.
TOOK A
IN HIS F THAT AS A ROOKIE.
COLE SILLINGER DROPS IT THERE
FOR NYQUIST.
STEPS IN OVER THE LINE, DEALS O.
>> Jody: QUICK GLOVE FROM ELVIS,
NICE JOBP AS GAVRIKOV  BENCH, T
PLAY IT OFF THE LEFT   ON
TO BOQVIST.
CUT OFFORGANIZED.
AND AS
IT OFF THE WALL.
HERE'S RIGHT ACROSS THE
GOAL MOUTH OUT THE OTHER SIDE.
PELECHCHL BE A MAN SHORT.
>> Jody: YOU KNOW, YOU GET IN
THE DEFENSIVE  LEG AND WIDE.
JENNERMAN, OLIVER BJORKSTRAND
STARTED WITH THE FORECHECK AND
A LATE
HERE LATE IN THE
SILLINGER, 18 YEAR OLD, YOUNGEST
PLAYER IN THE BEAN.
SILLINGER, ROLLING PUCKOWARDS T.
THIS IS DOBSON MOVING IN.
DOBSON THE HIM MAN BARZAL.
NOW KEEP AN EYE ON MARTIN IN
FRONT AND HOCKEY
GLASS, PUCK PICKED UPEEKE
SHOWING THE AGGRESSIV ISLANDER
FORWAR
WITH A SHOT, ELVIS THE SAVE,
SCRAMBLE IN FRONT AND IT WA THE
GAVRIKOV.
PEEKE'S GOT TO HUSTLE.
PALMIERI COMING. DOWN LOW.KI AN
IT.
THAT PUCK WAS